so a lot of this stuff I always
vacillate between that everything bad in
the world is the media's fault
and everything is politicians fault but
really it's both of them right like when
you watch the White House Correspondents
Dinner and you really see how close
these guys are and you know they call it
nerd prom and they think they're so edgy
and cool because they're all nerds
together but it's like you guys are
going to parties together you guys are
going to dinners together there are a
good jillion examples of politicians
being married to members of the media or
their children or in the media or every
type of nepotistic connection you can
possibly imagine do you think it's
basically 50/50 at who's at fault over
how screwed up our our whole
conversation is no I think it's entirely
due to the left and then I know really
listen you talk what do you really think
yeah yes you talk about media
entertainment industry it's entirely to
the left wildly to the left and so
you're right about these relationships
right these cozy relationships between
media and members of you know members of
office but then they try and take them
they go so mainstream media is just it's
funded by the Koch brothers and Big Oil
listen you cannot tune in to CNN MSNBC a
they could go Fox News Fox News Fox News
okay what about ABC NBC CBS CNN MSNBC
every single other news source it's not
Fox News is pushing the clot the
man-made global climate climate change
agenda so I have to get that right it's
not global warming they're always
pushing you know the LGBTQA AIP agenda
right now with with the laws in North
Carolina they're always pushing the anti
corporate anti Republican agenda so
people think because there's some kind
of corporate influence that it
automatically means that media is
conservative it couldn't be further from
the truth you can look at the numbers
you can look at the statistics an
overwhelming number of people not only
in executive positions but people who
work in the industry whether it's
Hollywood music or media are entirely
entirely left so if people watch it and
they think that they're dishonest or
they feel like the mainstream media has
misled them I would agree that rests
entirely at the feet of the left
Republicans have had plenty of
opportunities and they've screwed it up
to Fox News included and a lot of AM
radio I get
but the reason Fox News and AM radio are
singled out by the left is because those
are the only two mediums that aren't
100% dominated by far left influencers
so I want to make sure people who are
watching this in to the young audience
good corporate media man it's still to
the left very far to the left and I hope
people realize that yeah I Ben Shapiro
laid out a very similar case for that
when he was on but all right I know a
lot of my audience is gonna be shaking
their fist that some of the things you
just said so let's back up a little bit
climate change now I had Michael Mann
dr. Michael Mann from Penn State he's
one of the most respected climate
scientists in the world he laid out the
case for climate change he laid out the
97% of scientists in this field that
believed that manmade climate change is
real so alright that's I let him on for
an hour and laid it out so I'll give you
two minutes to debunk I got to go listen
I'm not going to debunk climate change
but the 97% is [ __ ] if you look at
the questionnaire basically if you
didn't believe in climate change you
were not included in the sample study
this is taken from two examples people
can look it up we've written about it on
the website there is a petition out
there now again I'm not a scientist so
I'm not going to talk from the point of
view of a scientist but I will talk from
the point of view of consensus
little-known fact science isn't governed
by consensus it's governed by what's
right but if we're going to use the
consensus argument there's a petition
out there with over 30,000 registered
scientists several thousand atmospheric
scientists which means that right away
you're in double digit percentage points
of the qualified atmospheric scientists
proactively going out of their way to
sign a pledge saying we don't believe in
either manmade climate change or that
man-made climate change will have the
catastrophic results that these people
are pushing that number is patent
[ __ ] and a great example and we ran
this is when you have Ted Cruz in there
and four with a Sierra Club the head of
the Sierra Club and he asked them about
the pause this is the head of the Sierra
Club the most influential environmental
impact Lobby in DC we want to talk about
corruption in Ted Cruz I want to know
how you explain the pause the head of
the Sierra Club goes to his intern well
we would like to rely on the consensus
of the 97% but those scientists are
pointing people at the Sierra Club in
the Sierra Club appeal this head of the
Sierra Club doesn't have any numbers to
back it up do I think that the climate
is changing yeah
is it possible that there's manmade
climate change maybe will that have
catastrophic results we can't prove that
yet
people don't agree on that you you want
to wait you want to wait till Miami is
uh Miami's are supposed to be gone
Dave anyone who watched in Inconvenient
Truth which was the big catalyst that
put Al Gore on a board at Apple to
collect billions of dollars while
masseuses were rubbing his feet and he
was doing their arches know that all
these predictions were wrong they were
verifiably false there's more ice in the
Antarctic than ever before I'm not
saying there's no way that humans could
be contributing to climate change but to
believe that it is going to have
catastrophic results and to believe that
the United States government can fix it
is ridiculous and how do they want to
fix it more legislation more control
more power so when someone if someone
has a vested interest here again if I
could get big oil money if I could get
big fracking money I would take it and
let you know I've not received a dime
but if someone's grant depends on them
saying that the earth is warming and we
need to fix it now those people have a
vested interest in proving their theory
and they're not disclosing it and all
they do is say I'm funded by big oil I'm
just saying that I'm pretty skeptical
and have looked at the list of 30,000
scientists signing a petition just that
list means the 97% number is complete
[ __ ] if that were a valid scientific
argument which it isn't
all right well in the spirit of healthy
discussion I had man on you just I gave
you your two minutes you took every
second of it and now let people do a
little googling that's a thing right and
let them let them see what they think
and then I'll bring it I'm not mad at
you I just know this goes relative
scientists I'm not a scientist I'm not
I'm not claiming to be a scientist by
the way big fracking money is that a
thing because I would love to be IO I'm
funded by the big fracking people that
sounds that just sounds good
well that's a big part of what's it
contributed to nearly all of the new
employment under Barack Obama's
presidency despite his best efforts it
is an amazing it is a miracle fracking
is an absolute miracle for United States
energy dependence but I guess left us
want us to be dependent on countries
like Saudi Arabia where they have no
EPA's they couldn't give two shits about
a clean atmosphere and ship it on
tankers overseas the BP oil spill exxon
valdez that happens every every year
multiple times a year in the middle of
the ocean you just don't see it so
there's no seagull caught in the oil
spill that people feel bad about on a
CNBC report and people act like we're
getting what what do you think your
electric car what do you think the
energy comes from two giant non
recyclable batteries most of our
electricity United States a significant
portion still comes from coal you're
plugging it in using coal energy people
just don't use it's a white guilt thing
it's a social justice warrior white
guilt and I'm not saying that someone
cannot make a valid argument for climate
change I'm not saying that and if that
scientists were on here with me he would
eat my lunch I absolutely agree but when
you are trying to take away my private
rights as an American citizen that's
where I have the right to be skeptical
and you have Bill Nye saying that we
should be jailed now that's crazy all
right so I'm with you on that and of
course as a more limited government guy
I'm with you on the idea that government
can't solve everything if the climate
really is out of control the idea that
the United States government or even the
UN you know they get together and they
have all the Kyoto conference and this
the Paris thing that they had and all
this stuff they get together they say
all these things literally everything
they say is non-binding there's no
enforcement that the UN has to do any of
these things so they sign these papers
they say oh this is what we're going to
do over the course of next 30 years and
you know whether they do you know yeah I
went to the climate summit yeah the one
in Cancun yeah people who say oh it was
fear-mongering first off the Kyoto
Protocol is total and complete utter
horseshit and it would destroy people in
third-world countries who need energy
you know these people aren't time up
about running their cars they're trying
to feed a can of beans over an ironing
board in the trashcan right so your
solar panels might feel good if you're
living out there in Palm Springs these
people can't afford it
suddenly I was there I was there when
Ted Turner got up on stage and proposed
communist China's one-child policy he
wanted that to be binding on the
protocol I was there when he proposed
that so when people say you're your I'm
the extremist just saying hey let's wait
a little bit and this guy is getting up
with world leaders proposing a one-child
policy by the way how do you enforce
that I can do the googling it's not by
writing an angry letter these people are
extremists they're religious extremists
and that's my issue not a debate over
scientific consensus but when someone
wants to tell me I can't have more than
one child govern
it mandated we have some problems okay
so let's let's split the difference for
the sake of the conversation let's say
between between Michael Mann and what
you've said that the truth is somewhere
in between maybe it's a little
human-made and let's say something's
happening let's say maybe it's not even
humanity but let's just say something's
happening right now sure so for you as
someone that obviously economics is a
big part of what you think and you know
what you care about what the
government's role should be is based in
economics don't you think that the
government could perhaps do a little
more to invest in green energy so that
there's still an economy there so you're
not so maybe maybe we'll burn less coal
but there's a lot of money to be made in
wind power and solar power and all of
those other things like so there you're
not losing
you're just shifting where money is not
losing money or you gotta not lose your
jobs what's that are you out of your
tree sir it's al Indra look at green
companies the biggest green company I
think in the world I know everyone yells
Solyndra I know that's one that's well
not cilinder but another one last week
just went bankrupt I don't have it in
front of me we wrote about it on the
website it consistently doesn't work
when you try and force the market and
manipulate the market that's how you end
up with big bank bailouts that's how you
end up with the housing crisis that's
how you end up with Solyndra it doesn't
work there are people who are going to
respond to market forces and we're going
to get better energy we're going to find
other ways to power us through the next
century by the way we have more than
enough energy right now in natural
resources for more than a century of
peak oil myth is another thing it's a
myth particularly now that you include
fracking into the equation no I don't
think the government should step in and
force companies to and the only way they
can do that now is force companies to
invest in wind or solar and inevitably
they end up going bankrupt because it
doesn't work and by the way a big reason
it doesn't work is because of Democrats
right why were wind wind turbines killed
out there on the East Coast because of
people like Ted Kurt
Turner who didn't want to look at them
and they were killing Eagles or if it
was why were solar panels killed in
Mojave Desert because of some endangered
species of mosquito or insect I don't
even know why mosquitoes exist I think
you could feed fish with something that
is much less annoying I don't get it but
that was the reason in the Mojave Desert
if you can't put solar panels in the
Mojave Desert and you can't put wind
turbines off the cake coast of Cape Cod
you can't do it yeah you know I was
driving up to a couple months back I was
driving up to
Noma from here in LA and there's a huge
swath of area where you pass tons and
tons of turbines in the mountains you
know it's nobody lives near them or
anything I actually thought it looked
really cool like it felt like I was like
oh this is what the future is but yeah I
guess people don't don't want that in
their backyard but all right let's let's
leave that one but liberals do it that's
the problem liberals say you have to
invest in this and then screw you on the
other side we're going to give you a
grant we want you to what we're gonna
punish you with some kind of terrorists
if you don't invest enough green energy
okay fine let's put up these panels in
Maumee desert can't do that there's a
mosquito are you [ __ ] me that's the
process they're wrong on every turn I'm
just saying let them do what's most
profitable as long as they're obeying
the rules and then we don't have to
screw a company and bail them out with
taxpayer down so if anything you I think
you think you're being the true
environmentalist by not killing the
birds that are flying into these things
I don't care about birds birds are jerks
but birds are jerks birds are jerks all
right good finish for that one all right
so let's talk about the abortion thing
for a little bit because this is the one
that I think there is so little middle
ground and I think if people really
would talk about it in an honest way and
not constantly demonize everyone else's
intent I think we could make a little
headway so you're against abortion
altogether right you or do you have some
exceptions here's what I do okay yeah I
think it's murder do I think the best
way to deal with an incest or rape
problem is to kill the child no but
since it's less than a single percentage
point of abortions okay let's take it
off the table let's say fine for that
our liberals are left us willing to do
anything else to curb abortions are they
willing at all to deviate from free
abortion on demand any time period and
they're not okay so I'm with you on the
so I think I'll say it you took a
principled approach there you're saying
that there's this 1% now every way make
everyone makes it sound like the the
rape situation or the mother dying is a
much bigger percentage than it is so I'm
gonna take your word that it is 1% I'll
go with you on that one fact check me at
all just take my word for it that's what
I live for Dave
again google people but ok so that
you're taking a pretty you're saying I'm
willing as someone that believes this is
murder I'm willing to just throw that
out for the for the sort of good of the
conversation so okay I think that's a
pretty decent place to start I mean my
feeling on it is at some point I do
believe that it is murder I mean I don't
know for me it's like I don't know what
the point is I don't know if that's at
and this is of course with scientists
and philosophers and you know right
people have debated forever you know is
it the second the sperm touches the egg
I don't think so I think there might be
a couple months in there where it's the
cosmic stew before it is a human but you
know I've had I've had people on my show
when I've talked about abortion who have
said until it is literally out of the
woman's body you can have an abortion I
would never go for that I mean there
were babies born at five months because
something's wrong and they live they're
perfectly normal lives
well so that's what that's voted ya know
I defend babies that were born from
survived abortions and being tossed in a
linen closet in Illinois he was the only
person of any democrat or republican in
the state who said no we don't need to
protect them these babies who have
survived abortions let him die in a
linen closet and he said because there
were already laws in the books the
reason this was there on the floor for a
vote was because it wasn't working so
again if we want to talk radical babies
who are breathing who are crying who are
left in a linen closet to die Barack
Obama voted to ensure that could still
happen as opposed to voting present
which he did a significant amount of
time again so I don't think it's
extremists for me to say all right let's
toss those out what can we do to limit
abortions versus someone saying now even
if they survived the abortion that's the
lady's choice let it die and again it's
been painted from the social justice
where you're left because right away I'm
a sexist or even you for what you said
you would have feminists who would be
all over you and what's your you have no
right at any point even though there's a
scientific argument to be made at
conception or much earlier than
feminists want to admit it doesn't
matter were considered the extremists
because we're against it at all and I
don't I don't think that what I'm saying
is untenable or less reasonable than
Barack Obama's voting record on abortion
I think it's far more reasonable right
well that's why I hate this discussion
is so stupid because the right makes it
sound like the left just wants to kill
babies and the left makes it sound like
the right just hates women and neither
one of those things are true I assume
the left once you're married to a woman
aren't you so I'm pretty sure you're Pro
woman I'm not you Dave I'm married to a
woman that's it we that's what marriage
oh it's been oh right right right we'll
get to that one too um so okay so I
would oh so stupid a Palm Beach there's
an old person this is gonna be sick
it didn't real heat my actual and I
should my wife just like I can't believe
about human bring someone who shot me no
no no no not about me but about someone
else who clearly was and then I don't
know and I was just been ringing in my
head I was looking for an excuse to do
it I'm sorry well you're working out too
much you know I do mean that's that's
the tip-off for a lot of people so okay
so with the abortion thing so if you
take the position as you've just laid
out and you were to for not force women
to have babies it sound it sounds silly
but you know say a woman can't have an
abortion but she can't afford it
she doesn't want the child etc etc would
you be for having the government helped
in some way once that child is in the
world because that's where I think we
can maybe get to a little common ground
on this it's one thing to say all right
why don't I get abortion but then you
know what there's still a child there
who's ultimately the victim because of
because of the parents poor decision to
either have sex in the first place or or
go ahead and do what they had to do well
I disagree with your premise forced to
have a baby you know again if we're
taking away the less than a percentage
point of a percent with rape and incest
no no I get it people are gonna have sex
no no I get that but I'm talking about
after that people are gonna make
mistakes people are going to miss
important because they oppose anything
that would prevent that situation a
great example is listen and I'm not a
huge fan of all the foreign aid that
George Bush did but who did the most
good for Africa the AIDS epidemic than
any all presidents combined was George
Bush and it wasn't even close and it
wasn't just because of money it's
because he was the first guy people
don't like him because as a Christian
and they hate the abstinence education
but he went in and said hey if you rape
a virgin you're still going to have AIDS
you guys should actually abstain from
sex let's teach the morality as it
relates to sex and then throw some
condoms at them and it worked
verifiably it worked same thing with
with Christian conservatives here in the
United States someone's saying listen
the only
thing that stops this idea that
abstinence only education that's not a
mainstream thing it's not a thing okay
abstinence only means the only thing
that works is abstinence the only thing
that can guarantee you won't get
pregnant to prevent an STD is abstinence
left us don't want to do that because
that's a moral absolute that needs to be
taught to kids and then you can teach
them to be more responsible but the
leftist voting constituency listen
they're not becoming more sexually
responsible the left has done a great
listen let's just talk about the black
American community a huge disservice a
black child has the likelihood of being
born as they do of being aborted at this
point it's almost a 50/50 shot and that
was a proactive set up from people like
Sanger in underprivileged neighborhoods
there is no reason in 2016 that they
shouldn't learn and if the Democrats
want to talk about helping impoverished
communities that they should not have
measurably improved these numbers of
people getting pregnant or accidental
pregnancies they haven't they have no
interest in doing that
so my fight has always been along
further on the beginning of that logic
bus right where you can ding-ding let's
get off here and the left doesn't want
to because inevitably it comes back to
more control and Planned Parenthood and
federal funding yes I support adoption
we've considered adopting I think it's a
great thing
if you look at people who adopt it tends
to be Christian conservatives as a
general rule or transsexuals depending
on what's what the theme of the day is
if you're watching I am Cait um but but
it's true they were all upset and I I'm
Caty like can you believe that I have to
disclose that I'm trans yes if you're
trying to adopt a child as a mother I
think it would be important information
that you have a dick I don't think
that's hate speech to check that box
does have this not allowed to make hair
you said [ __ ] like five times
yeah no you're allowed hey listen you
know I told you I have a crack team of
researchers here they just flash in
front of me as you were talking about on
your 1% stat on the on the rape thing
they're saying the closest person the
closest they can find to the 1% thing
was a study done in 1989 so there you go
so but I think your point is that maybe
it's 5% maybe it's 1% I would like to
hear them come up with a different
number because again the left doesn't
even want to present a number they just
want to say well what about what what
about if there's a sigh a me I've heard
even heard this in college humanities
class right and then will people right
when you learn correlation doesn't
causation and a few buzz words are like
Young Turks really just play the
drinking game with mainstream media
right but they don't want to educate
themselves and what that actually means
the left should present some numbers on
that they don't want to they operate in
the dark I want to shine a light on as
much of it as possible but yeah it's
hard to get those numbers because people
don't want to report rape and so the
left says you just have to take our word
for it one in four women is raped and if
you argue against it you're sexist which
is a complete total BS number that means
one of every four women we know has been
raped
anyone with a shred of common sense
knows it's it's a lie yeah well that
goes to the lack of trust that I think
the mainstream media without using that
as the the pejorative style but just you
know the the cable news operation has
just become just terrible in the way
that it reports news you know they're
basically just doing panels all day of
people that got everything wrong six
months before and they just rope them
out again right I mean you can literally
I was watching CNN the other day and
it's like oh there's Gloria Borger again
she predicted everything wrong let's now
what's she going to predict they do this
with everybody and then of course it's
also campaign managers debating other
campaign managers you are never going to
get anything remotely close to true and
then of course their analysts are also
former administration officials whose
jobs it used to be to lie you know if
you're Jay Carney the press secretary
and now you're now you're supposed to be
an analyst it's the height of stupidity
so that's mainstream media find it's
easy to knock it as you just alluded to
but I also think there's a huge danger
now with what's going on with the online
media that has completely dropped the
ball I think there was a moment there
was about a three year window a couple
of years back where the online media
started doing some really beautiful
stuff really talking about things in a
new way talking about money in politics
talking about real issues that just
couldn't percolate up to the mainstream
and then what happened is everyone
jumped in and said well I'm a news guy
I'm a you know and I say this with all
due irony I do the best I can here but
I'm you know I'm in the online world I
hold myself to you I don't sell yourself
short
listen you actually try you're not just
regurgitant you're not just
regurgitating clickbait Credle right
thank you I respect that
so people
watching should should appreciate that
about you have people out there who made
millions in online media and never so
much as written an original column
because they've just figured out we
spend X amount in advertising and we
make this amount back by just
aggregating the best stories with a hat
tip at the bottom and you're right it's
a real problem right so there's a lot of
that and there's just new sites popping
up every day funded by a lot of times
people with a lot of money to push an
agenda and it's all being presented as
news so how do you navigate what you
find is true and what you find is worth
listening to I think it's really hard to
do I mean even when you know I try to
follow things that I don't agree with
and I follow some things I agree with
and half the time I'm like I don't know
if either one of these are giving me
anything close to the truth no I think
you're right and that's a real problem
we've been plagiarized a lot and I know
they'll accuse anyone of being clickbait
because we do anywhere from four to six
articles a day compared to 60 or 70
which is typical of these places just
have staffs of people and all they do is
find out a title you know like for me it
was a point where we severed
relationships just when they were just
Marco Rubio billionaire secret closeted
gay boy toy okay you know this is enough
like you know I can't can't even be
friends with you people that's been a
big problem with the Trump situation you
know you have these people who support
Trump who work for some of these big
sites and we've even received backroom
threats if we don't step up and get in
line for Trump from conservatives they
see me as more of an enemy than leftist
and I'll praise Trump when he's been
right and I've criticized him when he's
been wrong same thing with Ted Cruz or
Marco Rubio but the issue is they'll
also go out and go look we have these
numbers you know a few of these
conservative sites that sites that
supported Trump did way better than
those who didn't it's changing guys well
all that says is you're just you know
clickbait crap and you're proud of it it
doesn't matter if it's true it doesn't
matter if it's if it's honest doesn't
matter if there's original content and
yet it is a real problem what I do and
what I recommend people do if they're
trying to figure out the truth follow
you people like The Young Turks I can't
stand them they're almost always wrong
HuffPo salon that's why we're the first
ladders Crider calm like we only have me
not gay Jerrod Courtney Casey Brody that
that's our entire staff but we're
constantly reading salon and HuffPo and
BuzzFeed and then responding to it
because most conservatives don't even
have it on the radio
so I always recommend just listen no one
is unbiased have stuff that's far the
left have stuff that's far to the right
so you at least know what both sides are
saying and then draw your own
conclusions trying to do the CNN we're
straight down the middle thing it's a
lie it's never existed so I always
recommend that people have both clear
left and right and make their decisions
because either way someone's going to
try and pitch you yes so is the real
irony here that you know everyone says
well you know the mainstream media is
funded by the corporations and those are
the same corporations that are funding
the candidates and wobble-bottom there's
obviously some truth to that without
question and that shows why some of it
sucks but that the online media I don't
think people have sort of caught up to
what you just said which it is because
it's just driven by clicks the truth is
the first thing out the window because
all you want to do is write the most
salacious headline get somebody to click
out of Twitter get somebody to watch
that that ad on YouTube and all that and
I know very much for work from what we
did from literally day one I was the
first thing that I did on this show was
lay out the rules of how I'm gonna guide
this show and I said we're not gonna do
clickbait and I know even sometimes I'll
talk to my producers after and we'll
know that we can get more views if we
frame this a certain way or if we try to
rig the system and we go out of our way
not to do it because I'm trying to do
something that that I'm proud of but a
lot of these guys they just want clicks
and that's no better than being funded
by a corporation or anything else no no
absolutely not via that we could do
twice the numbers we've run the numbers
if we just talked about Trump non-stop
yeah and we don't we just don't do it
now there's difference you know you want
people to click your content you want to
grow you know our rule is anything we
title people it's a window right the
window to a shop they know exactly what
they're getting and then come in because
I want more not whoa the bombshell
Donald Trump drop that you won't believe
you know our title would be something
like Donald Trump accuses Ted Cruz of
extramarital affairs here's the evidence
I like the head wave you did with the
other one could you do that oh you will
believe absolutely
magical Rubio yeah you seize all the
time or sending you know Bernie Sanders
let the cat out of the bag on here you
recruit you know like if it doesn't let
anyone know and they have to click it to
find out what it is that's clickbait
having a title that people want to click
and learn more and we've learned listen
long-term what we've seen a lot of
companies drop like flies and listen
we're not perfect and we've screwed up
but our interactions on social media as
opposed to clicks far outnumber clicks
because the people who do read it click
it share it want other people to be
informed and so a lot of these people
have taken a crap on social media or
YouTube by just getting the click but
the retention rate is terrible or people
leave and and that's being fixed there's
an anti conservative bias at Facebook
but yeah I appreciate that you do have
integrity with this this program and
that you you do try and frame it that
way a lot of people out there don't and
I will say it's probably worse in the
conservative community than the left
because wow you're conceding some ground
I can see ground all the time listen
your hair is better than me right now
you've got a better makeup team get a
better vacation than I did you made
better choices with that um that's this
is true listen you're prettier than I am
but um yeah I think no I think there's
there's a lot of ground to be conceded
the thing I like about Donald Trump is
that he doesn't apologize when he
doesn't think he's wrong the problem is
he never thinks he's wrong if I'm wrong
I'll apologize if I don't think I'm
wrong I'm not going to apologize because
someone marches me out and that's a big
difference to between me and other
conservatives for you may have had on
the show no one pays me you know we make
ad revenue or YouTube or starting a
membership it won't change the free
content I pay my employees and hopefully
pay myself because I've worked for other
people and I know you've been in that
situation and it's a really tough
situation to be because someone else has
final call and you know I mean a good
example would be like I know you don't
want to talk about them because you
worked it but like The Young Turks I
think the stuff is just complete just
untrue it's just untrue or they go on
now they don't even try right it's just
Jensen oh come on simple stuff folks ok
don't be ridiculous and then he is or
games like yeah yeah and then they have
that guy who's clearly just trotted out
because he's gay and he just reiterates
what Anita says like there's Nita I
don't know her name I always forget
name um I'm just letting go I'm just
letting you go here is it Anita I'm just
letting you go I don't know if it is
fine whatever it is but they have that
guy come out like yeah yeah I totally
think you're right it was kind of like
when rachel maddow started and she was
come on and so every review piece and
that was it it's just it gets to a point
where there's no one on there to
question them so they can [ __ ] about
mainstream media all they want but they
do have funding of course people know
it's not like it's been always been
entirely independently run or they've
built their own studios people know that
there's some money behind them and they
have a vested interest in protecting a
narrative my only thing is I just ask
that people be honest yeah I just ask
people be honest about their point of
view and then let the cards fall where
they may if people do that we do not
have a problem even if you're Jesse
Ventura fluoride in the tap and
deodorant is a government form of mind
control go with it as long as you're
honest about it
that's my man Jesse Ventura an aura oh
that's right sorry I forgot you see what
you've correct we'll edit that out no
guess well we don't know at that out
because or is it a school us on the fact
that Jesse ventures no the fact the
flyed in your tap you know it's a
beautiful thing I've said this before
but the the beauty of my situation with
aura is from day one they said to me
don't make the show that you think we
want you to make make the show you want
to make and they have never once said
literally one word to me about editorial
or any of the direction we're doing
anyway listen we could talk forever and
I've thoroughly enjoyed this and this is
what the battle of ideas is all about so
to wrap this thing up do you think that
by 2020 that we will have a viable third
party because it's pretty obvious to me
that there is a new center growing a
people a group of people who are a
little more socially liberal and I know
you're obviously not a socially liberal
as I am but who have a little more of
that who have who want a smaller
government who want to figure out a
fairer tax system but still believe in
strong defense like I think there's
something really growing here who really
believe in free speech of course and all
that so do you think there is a moment
where we might get a third party coming
in 2020 that's my hope out of out of all
the craziness from this situation well I
have two questions for that and I know
we have to go where do you think that
I'm not a socially liberal as you well I
think if we do
skipped over the whole gay marriage
thing but I know you're basically okay
on it and I know you like to kind of
joke about it but you're basically it
doesn't reel in the state it's a state
issue and the Supreme gets a vile you
know Supreme Court again it's a power
grab that they had no authority to take
just like well they enjoy equal
protection clause so but we could argue
about the legalities of that all day
long but I got your point I know you're
basically there
well mild points that people will say
well Ted Cruz wants to ban dildos is
like an example C's group no he didn't
he was fighting for states rights
because there was some kind of dildo
banning thing in states I don't think
there should be a federal Department of
Education there was a dildo banning
thing did that go completely is it all
thing of course is put out and he was
fighting for states rights in front of I
don't know which High Court it was I
don't know if it was a Supreme Court the
point is yeah listen there can be an
absurd there can be a state law that
bans scary-looking hats they've existed
I think they're silly but I think a
state has the right to do that just say
again I think a state has the right to
declare polygamy legal if they want to
right if we're at that point the problem
with people is a supreme court and
people talk about abortion or talk about
social issues like I think drugs are a
state issue and so people think because
I'm deeply Christian conservative myself
and I'm open about it that somehow I
believe that should be enforced like
that I don't so I wanted to just clarify
that as far as third party well you say
fair taxi that comes I don't know what's
the what's people need to put a number
on it I'm not going to be standing in
the centrist party if I don't agree with
these people on policy and ideas free
speech is great but there's got to be
more to it than that and so I you know I
think the tea party was effective in
taking over the Republican Party and
keeping it accountable for a season and
now we have this this big problem maybe
you'll see that with a Democrat Party I
don't think you're going to see a third
party anytime soon that's viable and I
don't want to see a fracturing of the
votes we're like in Canada you can have
a prime minister who's elected with 35%
of the vote you know listen that's the
reason the two-party system exists it
doesn't this guy doesn't represent
everyone but 50 percent or so of the
population on both sides feel like there
is enough of a representation and that's
better than 15 candidates representing
this specific niche really really well
that's how you fragment it and they get
democratic socialism because all of a
sudden you have enough of a mob who
bands together and they can
democratically vote to take away someone
else's
right yeah I mean I hear you on that but
I'm the more I think about it I see that
50/50 thing as just being this much of
something that's really this big and we
don't talk about all those other ideas
out there so it's gonna be a gift Dave
Rubin good
oh no I walked right into that one all
right listen we're gonna flip the script
right now and I'm gonna join you on your
show so we're gonna put the link below
right over there on the on the YouTube
machine give me a plug give my site a
pop you didn't even plug anything I'm
about to do the plugs you guys could
check out louder with Crowder it's on
the YouTube and it's pretty much
everywhere you have like 18,000 methods
of distribution but it's youtube.com
slash steven crowder that's Steven with
a V and you want to do one other pimping
yeah what's ladder with crider comm
because sometimes we'll get banned stuff
either from YouTube or Facebook so latte
with credo commas where people can
subscribe to anything and there are
articles but I appreciate the valiant
effort and thank you for the plug